if you ever have to flee an airport
don't run out of departures because
that's we're expecting
you to go go down to arrivals because a
lot of other people
coming in there it's always a floor
under under departures
[Music]
we're talking about the
early 70s and
back at this time and like all teenagers
i absorbed the counter culture as much
as i could
and thought that revolution was what was
expected
to fight back against any authority
i went to a
a private school
but it was terrible it was all boys and
boring well i was asked to find another
school
over an incident with the
chemistry teacher
he accused me of wanting to make up a
batch of lsd of all things
but
really i didn't quite fit into that
this was a time when
drug use was not particularly
underground
my
my mother's friends were
pot smokers and i wasn't even a regular
smoker
but
on the the melbourne and the australian
drug scene
hard drugs were not
massively distinguished between anything
else
cocaine and heroin were just some things
that were also available
a girl i knew worked at a cinema
a boyfriend was a safe cracker when i
got to know these guys they
retired from safe cracking it was they
were too well known
and
they used to buy up a whole lot of grass
and weed when they could
and some hash
but they didn't have any way of getting
anything bigger
and they were saying that it was really
impossible
for them to bring it in
and being a little smart ass that i was
i thought really
and so that was the attraction
i'd left my
day job
and had to get funded by one of the guys
from the safecrackers group
now
he gave me a few thousand dollars and
and really didn't hold out much hope
that anything would come of it how did
it work in my case badly i made as every
conceivable mistake possible
when i first landed in india in search
of hashish
to get things going i got swindled
outside american express by some con men
there you know offering discount rates
then
couldn't find a good connection
i even
turned to the shoeshine boys on the
street
who managed to score me some pretty
rough edge but smokeable sort of hash
but
persistence and time will lead you to
the connections you need to make i had
so much to learn
i was lucky i survived a lot of errors i
arrived back in
sydney with
almost six kilos of hash at that time
there was um
they didn't use the systems that they
developed
it was just one
guy behind a a desk
and he unzipped my case
asked me where i'd been of course
and he looked inside inside there was a
1950s
grunting radio a big old thing that had
once had tubes and dials and levers
inside but now had nothing
there was no clever packing in this one
it was the hash bricks were just wrapped
up
stuffed inside stuff so
firmly the casing was buckled at the top
this customs officer knew perfectly well
i mean he even spun the dial of the
radio and it kept on spinning
no levers moved
he knew what it meant he looked around
to see if anybody was watching
because he wanted to let me go
and he looked at me rather firmly and
said
are you going back there no no no
we'll see that you don't and you can
take your uh
radio we'll call it and get going
what this family man didn't want
was to propel me
into the jail system the world of
prisons
i guess he was experienced enough to
know what that would mean
but you can imagine for somebody
[Music]
just turned 19
as i bounced out of the
airport terminal thinking myself the
cleverest smuggler around in fact
just some halfway that been given a
break
i began a series of operations with
um
a series of drug runs where i was taking
it myself
my wife at the time an italian girl who
father had restaurants
she was honored me not to be doing it
myself so
i
found helpers couriers i found one
in what turned out to be the best
courier i'd ever had
this guy ran a couple of plant shops
um
she she over decorated things with venus
fly traps and
crawling pumps and things he ruined them
he was just a spender of money
it was perfect for me
and he could imagine himself in
different worlds
i had peter once run
we went out of bangkok he had two kilos
the swap was done and he arrived at
belgium the system then was to change
passports in europe so that your
endpoint in this case it was a
transfer in the uk
you would arrive with documentation that
said you'd only been in europe
and i watched peter arrive
now without any
suggestion from me he turned himself
into
what was clearly a professional tennis
player
he arrived in
white shorts and t-shirt
uh even had the racquet in his hand and
it was an expensive one he was giving
the mx card i'd given him for expenses a
thorough bashing on that one
and i asked him
what he was thinking as he came through
untouched of course
he said i was thinking of the matches
i've won
and
the games i've played
and this was the kind of person who made
perfect couriers how did you move into
the position where you could actually be
arrested and imprisoned in australia
what was the journey there
the end came about in australia
due to
arrogance i was still after all only in
my early twenties
what did i have hmm i had a office a
couple of houses
spent money carelessly but not publicly
but i'd been reported
now
i knew the police were following me
because in
those days before encrypted radio
signals we could listen in on them
when the day came that um
i
write back home and said to my wife
clearly
hey some poor guy being watched in the
area
grab my hand held and go out and take a
look maybe i can tip him off
i threw the handheld in the car
switched the remote control for the
garage door and on the radio
said
yeah the garage door is coming up i said
what a break the guy's going out just
now
i'll really be able to watch him
i had the lcd is backing out we can see
the ford
and he's got a ford so i'm starting to
realize that this is me being watched
and there were no
slouch operatives
and i was given 15 years of which i had
to do 10.
at the end of a long sentence the usual
course is that people in low security
prisons and go home to a welcoming
family
though i had the welcoming family
it wasn't the usual path i was at a very
low security prison
but i was being followed from my day
leaves home
police were watching me they had even
visited me to say that they kind of
missed the old days when they used to
chase me around
and i found that
when i got home
they were there when i rented a flat
they were there they'd leave little
notes and abusive messages on
my answer phone
i couldn't move without them
so i backed away
and i left the country because i knew it
would never end with them
the plan was to go to europe to come
back to london
i'd had a few things here i had a safety
deposit box here so a little money but
most of it was in thailand because i'd
taken it back there with my
friend lee my contact there
it was a very odd thing to arrive in
thailand
i'd taken such precautions to get there
i
two false passports
that i'd gone through
virtually from the grave up from the the
death certificates and birth
certificates
nobody could know that i was leaving
because that would be the end too
after three days of
unknown freedom in thailand
i went to the airport to continue my
journey
i went to the check-in desk and handed
over my passport
and i was already getting an odd feeling
but
who doesn't at an airport check-in
and then she cross-checked against a
list
and she said i just a minute i have to
check something
she walked away with that passport
there are moments
when in the blinking of an eye you know
that everything you have done
has failed
i looked up
i could see a railing a couple of
uniform guys watching me i could see
some plain clothes watching me and
actually froze for a minute
because there was no of course there was
a theoretical backup plan there there
has to be the second passport
but it was just to walk away from
everything again
i'd lost
one life a second life
the one that i just
left in australia
but i didn't really have time to take a
think about that
i did back off
i
picked up my travel bag the important
one with
the money in the second passport
and went down to arrivals if you ever
have to flee an airport don't run out of
departures because that's we're
expecting
you to go go down to arrivals because a
lot of other people
coming in there it's always a floor
under under departures
i found a taxi in the middle of a scrum
of probably
hundreds
and through a lot of argument with his
fellow drivers bribed my way back onto
the highway going into town
driving back there even with the window
open my head was burning with rage that
i can't tell you how careful i'd been
i thought i'd been so that nobody could
detect where i was
arriving back into the city i took two
talks in a motorcycle as well
go to a travel agency we knew
uh old players retired a little travel
agency in bangkok i could use their
phone and maybe work out where to go
next
as i arrived there
in an arcade
having
and all these steps
to lose people
i see a pile of cigarette butts opposite
but you take these things in the corner
of your eye as i walked into the treble
agency
and headed for the phone
i could feel
the swing of the door behind me in the
air coming in and i connected it with a
cigarette butt somebody been standing
there waiting somebody knew that's where
i'd go to
i turned and there were three
plainclothes thai police
they said various things but it didn't
matter
one had a gun but there's nothing i
could do about that
take it out and shoot myself it's the
only shot i'd get off
as i was taken into chinatown police
station
i saw
the
american dea agent that
i knew from the australian case bill
shenman
and a couple of australian faces that uh
no doubt liaison staff
after arrest you spend seven days in the
local police cells then you get
transferred to a court
and that not going well and it never
does you go to the main prison
i learned many and terrible things about
the thai courts
that
virtually everybody is found guilty you
can fight your case and it means you
take longer
up to five years
even
pleading to a case takes a year and a
half
but i couldn't do that
i was charged with
the false passport um
the money which was now written up as uh
four thousand dollars seemed to have
disappeared
and they'd done a little sweep of the
airport and found enough drugs
to see me face the death penalty it only
takes over 25 grams for an airport case
and that will put you on death row
i would be
found guilty as and within two weeks
sentenced to death
from the moment i stepped into that
prison in bangkok escape was on my mind
i had my nose glued to the cracks in the
cell bar on the sleeping guard probably
60 feet down the way but the first
stroke
of that tungsten steel on these old bars
seemed to carry throughout the whole
building in an escape there's one thing
for sure everybody is alone
up until this point everything's okay
you know we go to the baggage thing
our bags ain't coming yeah
everybody else has got the bags right
and then the police just come around
with guns and save tamira you boom
hands up in the air